let's talk about an incredible
uh
ah what is it it's sort of like a set
like a like a circular firing squad
that's taking place
republicans
are increasingly worried that maybe
they're not going to do so well in
november of 2022 why well because the
polling says they might not do so well
and so
people like marjorie taylor greene
are now saying
i don't know that that many republicans
are going to vote
which may be true
and then she immediately repeats the big
lie that the 2020 election was stolen
which would only encourage republicans
not to vote well what do i mean by that
if you believe your vote doesn't matter
because it's going to be stolen or eaten
or flushed or whatever
then you are less likely to go out and
vote if i knew my vote wouldn't count
why am i going to take time to go out
and vote so even though they're worried
about low turnout republicans are
lowering turnout by insisting on the big
lie here's a clip from marjorie taylor
greene on graham allen's dear america
podcast i'm not familiar with the show
but she she appeared on it
um
it's like a cognitive dissonance almost
i'm a little more cautious all right so
am i i don't think it's gonna be a big
red wave um but but maybe it will be but
i'll tell you the biggest problem i'm
concerned about is i'm concerned about
the people that are still angry and
don't want to vote right and we need
them to vote because
no matter i mean i i mean i was i'm one
of the
first people that'll tell you i don't
believe uh the election results of 2020
have no problem absolutely not i believe
trump won i i objected proudly on
january 6 and i would do it again today
and tomorrow if i could um but but i
think there's people that feel that way
and they're still angry and they may not
want to vote but we have to if we don't
vote we are handing over victory to the
radical godless left and so to me that's
one of my concerns is i'm worried people
won't vote yeah listen guys i'm very
worried people won't vote because they
were angry that the election was stolen
and their votes didn't count and it was
stolen and their votes didn't count and
i'm furious furious furious about that
but we need people to vote well but why
would they vote if their votes going to
be stolen and not counted or whatever
this strategy
probably lost them the senate if you go
back and think about the 2020 election
there were the two special elections in
georgia there were uh it would these are
the seats ultimately won by raphael
warnock and john ossoff it was january
fifth of twenty twenty one
they spent the period between november
of twenty twenty and january five twenty
twenty one
insisting that their votes didn't count
that the entire thing is rigged that
they're gonna steal it again
and that depressed turnout and
ultimately they did lose and some of
those races were not i don't remember
the exact number let me see if i can
even find them january 5 2021 special
georgia election results let's see what
those were
um ultimately awesome one assaf won by
1.2 percentage points and warnock won by
two okay it is completely plausible that
insisting that it was all stolen and
it's all rigged for two months plus two
months basically between the november
election and the january special
elections that they lost control of the
senate because of that it could be 52 to
48 republicans were it not for this very
strategy and now marjorie taylor green
just repeats it she is encouraging
people not to vote by saying it was
stolen the votes didn't count on and on
and on
i don't believe in overt voter
suppression as a tactic to win elections
so you will never hear me say on this
show
stuff to try to trick republicans into
not voting i know that there are people
who say well
uh the
the ends justify the means and there are
some on the left who say it would be
fine to try to trick republicans into
thinking election day is a different day
than it is
or whatever
that's
that's beneath me i can't do that that
seems immoral to me
but i'm certainly not going to tell
republicans not to do it themselves and
if they want to continue insisting
insisting insisting
that it was stolen votes don't count it
could happen again it's all going to be
fraud
uh then by all means let them go ahead
and do that and see what the uh what
what the actual turnout is